bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public à ces nains à suivre cet
après-midi sur notre antenne la
déclaration du premier ministre jean
marc ayrault
il s'exprime sur le livre blanc de la
défense
le livre blanc qui je vous le rappelle a
été rendue publique le 29 avril dernier
par jean yves le drian
il définit les priorités stratégiques de
la france en matière militaire
afrique renseignements utilisation des
forces spéciales ou encore cyberdéfense
que la loi de programmation militaire la
lpm et bien traduira en termes
budgétaires à l'automne prochain
dès sa publication le livre blanc de la
défense pour 2013 avait suscité de
nombreuses critiques aussi bien à droite
qu'à gauche il faut dire qu'il prévoit
entre autres la suppression de 24 mille
postes dans l'armée française
alors sans plus tarder direction
l'hémicycle pour suivre ce débat bon
après midi à tous l'ordre du jour
appelle une déclaration du gouvernement
suivie d'un débat
en application de l'article 50-1 de la
constitution sur le livre blanc sur la
défense et la sécurité nationale la
parole est à monsieur jean marc ayrault
premier ministre
monsieur le président du sénat mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs 2 je vous
prie de bien vouloir excuser mon départ
après cette intervention puisque je dois
me rendre juste après à l'assemblée
nationale ce sera aussi le cas du
ministre de l'intérieur qui doit
répondre aux questions au gouvernement
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs le
nouveau livre blanc de la défense et de
la sécurité nationale fait oeuvre de
vérité et d'ambition nous le devions à
la france dont la sécurité est notre
priorité absolue
nous le devions aux français unis dans
le soutien à ceux qui ont fait le choix
de défendre notre pays nous le devions à
nos armées à nos soldats dont
l'engagement remarquable doit être
accompagné de perspectives claires et
confiante pour l'avenir je l'ait déjà
dire cette tribune au mali aujourd'hui
comme hier sur d'autres théâtres notre
armée et l'honneur de la france
la valeur de ces officiers la qualité de
ses soldats assure la défense de notre
pays et lui valent d'être respectée
partout dans le monde
c'est un héritage et c'est une garantie
pour l'avenir
cet avenir doit se bâtir de manière
lucide et responsable
il faut d'abord tenir compte de
l'évolution du paysage stratégique
depuis le lan le livre blanc de 2008 la
crise économique et financière
les révolutions aux arabes l'évolution
de la posture des états unis les
difficultés que traverse l'europe pour
ne citer que l'essentiel mais il faut
également rétablir une véritable
cohérence dans la durée entre l'analyse
des défis posés à notre sécurité et les
moyens de notre pays se dote pour y
faire face le modèle dessiné par le
précédent livre blanc nous avaient
conduits dans une certaine forme
d'impasse les plus hauts responsables
militaires avertis c'est dès 2011
que certains des contrats opérationnels
qu'il définissait était en pratique
inaccessible sur le plan stratégique
pardon sur le plan budgétaire la cour
des comptes relevait en juillet 2012
un écart d'au moins 3 milliards d'euros
entre les prévisions et les réalisations
et un soulignait que cet écart ne
pouvait que ça 3 de façon vertigineuse
si de nouvelles orientations n'était pas
prise parce que notre responsabilité est
que la france conserve la maîtrise de
son destin
notre devoir impérieux était de définir
ces nouvelles orientations
tel est l'objet du nouveau livre blanc
il dessine véritable ambition pour la
défense et la sécurité nationale tout en
intégrant pleinement la nécessité d'un
redressement des comptes publics
car ce redressement était calme est
également une condition essentielle de
notre propre souveraineté
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs notre projet s'appuie sur
une analyse sans complaisance des
risques des menaces auxquelles la france
est confrontée ce sont les menaces de la
force qu'il s'agisse des conflits entre
états dont beaucoup affecte la sécurité
de l'europe de la prolifération des
armes de destruction massive ou encore
du développement par certaines
puissances de capacité informatique
offensive
ce sont les risques de la faiblesse
conséquence de la défaillance de
certains états a exercé les fonctions de
base de la souveraineté et sort des
trafics de la piraterie ou du terrorisme
voir chaos de la guerre civile
dans bien des cas la sécurité de
l'europe et donc de la france est mise
en cause mais c'est enfin
l'amplification de certaines menaces la
mondialisation facilite l'action des
réseaux terroristes ou la prolifération
et aggravent la vulnérabilité des
systèmes d'information et des multiplie
les risques naturels sanitaires
ou technologiques susceptibles de
désorganiser profondément nos sociétés
la vérité c'est que les menaces qui
pèsent sur la france et sur l'europe
sont loin d'avoir diminué depuis 2008
nous apportons à ce constat une réponse
conforme aux exigences de défense et de
sécurité de la france mais aussi à la
mesure de nos engagements et de notre
place dans le monde
nous le faisons en partant d'une
définition claire et hiérarchisé de nos
priorités outre la protection de notre
territoire de nos ressortissants et la
continuité des fonctions essentielles de
la nation elles portent d'abord sur
l'environnement de l'europe de l'afrique
le golfe arabo persique et jusque dans
l'océan indien
surtout ses théâtres la france doit être
en mesure seuls ou en coalition de
s'engager de manière déterminante tout
en gardant la capacité de contribuer à
la paix et à la sécurité internationales
partout ailleurs dans le monde
le nouveau modèle d'armée que définit le
livre blanc et les missions qu'il permet
de remplir répondre en tout point à ses
priorités il s'agit tout d'abord de
garantir la protection permanente du
territoire et de la population française
avec les moyens de surveillance aérienne
et maritime approprié et des capacités
d'intervention sur le territoire en cas
de crise majeure
les forces terrestres pourront fournir
jusqu'à dix mille hommes en renforts des
forces de sécurité intérieure et de
sécurité civile il s'agit ensuite
d'assurer la permanence de la mission de
dissuasion garantie ultime contre les
menaces d'agressions qui ciblerait nos
intérêts vitaux
elle nous prémunit de tout chantage qui
paralyserait notre liberté de décision
et d'action
ces deux composantes océanique et
aéroportée confortée par le programme de
simulation seront maintenus dans le
respect du principe de stricte
suffisance
à ceux qui en critique la pertinence ou
même le coup le gouvernement répond
comme l'a fait le président de la
république dans son discours à
l'institut des hautes études de défense
nationale vendredi dernier que cette
garantie est plus que jamais
indispensable dans le contexte
stratégique d'aujourd'hui et qu'il n'est
pas excessif d'y consacrer un peu plus
de 10% du budget de la défense
il s'agit enfin de conforter nos
capacités d'intervention extérieure
outre une force de réaction immédiate de
deux mille trois cents hommes les armes
et pourront être engagés dans des
opérations de gestion de crise
internationale sur trois théâtres
distincts à hauteur de 7000 hommes c'est
plus pour faire une comparaison avec ce
que nous avons mobilisé pour le mali nos
armées pourront aussi être engagé dans
une opération de guerre contre des
adversaires doté de capacités étatiques
à hauteur de 15 mille hommes des forces
terrestres avec les composantes
maritimes et aériennes approprier nos
forces restent doté d'une capacité
d'entrer en premier dans tous les
milieux et d'une capacité à planifier et
à conduire ces opérations
seuls ou en coalition le modèle d'armée
défini par le livre blanc est donc
cohérent avec la nature et la diversité
de ses missions il répond d'abord à un
principe je le rappelle d'autonomie
stratégique
la france doit disposer à tout moment de
sa liberté d'appréciation de décision et
d'action pour prendre l'initiative
d'opérations qu'elle estimerait
nécessaires comme elle l'a fait je le
rappelle encore en réponse à l'appel à
l'aide du mali
elle doit aussi pouvoir assumer son rôle
en toute souveraineté au sein d'une
alliance ou d'une coalition
ce modèle d'armée repose par ailleurs
sur le choix de différencier
l'équipement des forces en fonction des
exigences propres à chaque type de
mission et celui de pousser plus loin la
mutualisation de capacités polyvalente
est rare
le format de nos armées permet de
remplir entièrement l'émission que je
viens d'évoquer
ils portent haut les ambitions de la
france dans le monde et nos alliés ne
s'y sont d'ailleurs pas trompés en salma
le projet que dessine ce nouveau livre
blanc
monsieur le président du sénat mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs je ne méconnais
pas pour autant l'ampleur de
l'ajustement que ce nouveau modèle va
imposer à l'ensemble du ministère de la
défense
il entraîne une réduction de 24 mille
postes par rapport au modèle défini en
2008 mais qu'il faut mettre en
perspective avec les 54 mille
suppressions décidées à l'époque cette
réduction devra préserver au mieux les
unités opérationnelles ce qui exigera
une évolution de l'organisation mais
aussi du ministère lui-même et je fais
toute confiance à jean yves le drian qui
mène avec beaucoup de compétence et de
sang-froid sa mission pour conduire avec
détermination et discernement
cette nouvelle étape de la réforme en
cohérence avec le nouveau livre blanc
nous nous attacherons à limiter autant
que possible les conséquences de ces
évolutions pour les territoires la plus
grande attention sera portée
j'y veillerai personnellement à la
situation concrète de chacun d'entre eux
mais aussi au dialogue avec les élus et
avec à l'accompagnement des évolutions
nécessaires
le prenons aussi toute la mesure des
efforts exigés des personnels de la
défense
la précipitation qui a marqué les années
passées à provoquer des désordres
d'inacceptable qui illustre les dérives
du système de paie louvois cela doit
être absolument corriger
je sais que le ministre la défense qui
d'ailleurs dès les premiers mois de sa
prise de fonction a perçu tout de suite
qu'ils avaient un problème d'y consacrer
toute son énergie
les évolutions mises en oeuvre seront
assorties de mesures incitatives
indispensable réussite dans le cadre
d'une politique de ressources humaines
favorisant une gestion active des
carrières et ses évolutions s'appuieront
sur un dialogue social enrichie et une
rénovation du dispositif de concertation
au sein des armées
nos soldats et nos officiers doivent se
sentir pleinement soutenu et respecté
c'est aussi là que dans leur vie
quotidienne s'exprime la reconnaissance
de la nation
de même la réflexion fructueuse qui a
associé défense et justice pour prévenir
une judiciarisation excessive de
l'action militaire se traduira dès la
future loi de programmation
j'ai pleine confiance dans l'engagement
des hommes et des femmes de la défense
pour faire vivre et réussir ce nouveau
modèle
les opérations récentes soulignent la
qualité de cet engagement
elle nous en rappelle l'exigence mais
aussi la valeur et je leur renouvelle
ici l'hommage de la nation toute entière
nos soldats doivent bénéficier d'un
entraînement conforme aux exigences de
leur mission et il fera l'objet de toute
notre vigilance
ils doivent pouvoir mettre en oeuvre
avec une disponibilité suffisante des
équipements performants leur
renouvellement se pousuivra selon les
priorités retenues en faveur des
capacités de dissuasion de
renseignements et de projections ont
lacunes relevées lors des dernières
interventions répond l'effort engagé
dans le domaine du transport aérien du
ravitaillement en vol et aussi des
moyens de renseignement mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs ce modèle
d'armée consolide une démarche de
modernisation raisonner sans sacrifier
les effectifs nécessaires à l'action et
en veillant aux conditions d'activité et
nous permet de maintenir l'excellence de
notre outil de défense et il prépare et
préserve l'avenir
telle était notre préoccupation dans le
domaine de l'industrie de défense
sa vitalité est d'abord une condition de
la souveraineté et de l'autonomie
stratégique de la france mais elle est
aussi avec plus de
1000 entreprises de haute valeur ajoutée
et fortement exportatrice et environ 165
mille emplois un atout majeur pour le
dynamisme de notre économie et en
premier lieu de notre industrie
les choix qui ont été faits préserve
l'essentiel le rythme de renouvellement
des équipements sera ajustée mais nous
avons veillé à éviter toute rupture et à
garantir ainsi le maintien de
l'excellence et du potentiel de notre
industrie de défense
de même les efforts de recherche seront
maintenues au niveau atteint en 2013
enfin nous apporterons dans le strict
respect de nos engagements européens et
internationaux et avec un souci de
transparence accrue envers le parlement
un soutien actif aux exportations de
défense
ce projet conforte aussi la démarche que
nous menons pour tirer parti de la
construction européenne et de notre
place dans l'eau table
il nous permettra de poursuivre la
mobilisation pour construire l'europe de
la défense
nous connaissons ses limites actuelles
mais nous en mesurons aussi tout le
potentiel dans un contexte où la
contrainte financière suggère davantage
de synergies et pour répondre à des
menaces largement commune
nous avons tout à gagner à des
interdépendances librement consentis
nous allons donc progressé là aussi avec
pragmatisme en favorisant les opérations
communes en développant ensemble des
capacités propice à la mutualisation
comme le transport aérien le
ravitaillement en vol
les drones ou les satellites
d'observation et en favorisant bien sûr
des programmes de coopération en
relançant le rapprochement de nos
industries de défense dont l'intégration
dans la filière des missiles offre un
exemple réussi
nous devons construire des champions
européens et leur permettre un meilleur
accès à certains marchés internationaux
notre démarche s'appuiera sur des
partenariats d'excellence celui que nous
avons noué avec le royaume uni doit en
inspirer d'autres où elle doit affirmer
aussi une
amis qu à l'échelle de l'union toute
entière celle ci s'est donné un rendez
vous sur le sujet au conseil européen de
décembre de cette année et cet
engagement européen résolu va de pair
avec une participation pleine et entière
à l'automne comme l'a souligné le
président de la république la france
il conservera son identité et son
autonomie elle doit y intensifier aussi
son influence en veillant à ce que les
initiatives qui sont développés conforte
la dynamique européenne
c'est dynamique européenne est également
présente dans les autres dimensions de
la sécurité nationale de l'analyse des
risques jusqu'aux actions
civilo-militaires de prévention de
stabilisation ou de gestion de crise au
plan national un contrat générale
interministérielle fixera et préservera
les capacités civiles nécessaires à ses
missions
en complément des moyens militaires
mobilisable en cas de crise grave
une attention particulière sera portée
aux outre-mer et à la combinaison des
capacités militaires et civils
nécessaires à la protection de chaque
territoire et le livre blanc entérine
aussi un effort prioritaire et
indispensable en faveur du renseignement
c'est d'ailleurs une des clés de
l'autonomie stratégique de la france
elle est essentiel à notre sécurité
notamment dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme le renforcement des moyens
humains et techniques des services
s'accompagnera d'une extension des
prérogatives du parlement afin qu'ils
puissent pleinement exercer son contrôle
de la politique gouvernementale dans ce
domaine enfin le livre blanc défini une
stratégie ambitieuse de cyber défense
qui permettra de renforcer le niveau de
sécurité des systèmes d'information vito
et le parlement sera saisi de mesures en
ce sens elle développera nos capacités à
identifier les attaques et le cas
échéant à riposter de manière adéquate
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs ces choix
reflètent une double exigence
le maintien d'un effort de défense
volontariste et le retour à l'équilibré
de nos comptes publics en 2017
en euros constants la nation consacrera
à la défense 364 milliards d'euros entre
2014 et 2025 dont soit 179 dire que le 2
milliards sur la période de la future
aux futures lois de programmation les
premières années de cette programmation
nous maintiendrons un effort annuel de
31 4 milliards d'euros soit le montant
auquel nous l'avons stabiliser en 2012
et 2013 et le retour à l'équilibré des
comptes publics nous permettra ensuite
d'accentuer cet effort et conjuguera
crédits budgétaires et ressources
exceptionnelles qui sont identifiés et
qui seront intégralement affectés à la
mission des sens le projet de loi de
programmation militaire sera transmis au
parlement cet été et le président de la
république le rappelait dans son
discours que j'ai évoqué il ya quelques
instants à l'institut des hautes études
de la défense nationale
la france a besoin d'une défense forte
pour rester ce qu'elle est une grande
nation un allié fiable
une puissance qui porte à l'échelle
mondiale des responsabilités éminentes
je sais mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
monsieur le président de la commission
que vous partagez cette ambition les
réflexions que vous avez conduite
d'ailleurs en témoigne ainsi que
l'implication de vos représentants dans
les travaux de la commission dont je
salue la qualité la disponibilité et qui
ont contribué eux aussi à la préparation
de ce livre blanc au terme des choix que
nous avons arrêté avec le président de
la république
ce livre blanc dessine un modèle
renouvelée mais fidèle à cette ambition
est porteur d'avenir
notre défense il faut en être fier parce
que l'état en cohérence avec ce qu'est
la france restera au premier rang en
europe la france demeurera l'une des
seules puissances au monde
à disposer à la fois d'une dissuasion
nucléaire autonome d'une capacité
d'intervention extérieure éprouvée et
modernisé et d'une industrie de défense
performante
c'est une défense forte à la main à la
mesure de notre statut de membre
permanent du conseil de sécurité à la
mesure aussi de l'ambition que la france
porte pour elle même et pour ses
partenaires en europe et au service de
la paix dans le monde
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs je
souhaite que notre débat que votre débat
d'aujourd'hui permettent de renouveler
l'adhésion des représentants de la
nation à cet ambitieux projet mais je
sais à l'avant ce que c'est
l'attachement qu'ont sur tous les bancs
de cette assemblée les sénateurs et à
l'avance je vous remercie de l'appui que
vous appuierez pour cette nouvelle étape
de l'histoire de la défense nationale
merci monsieur premier ministre dans la
suite du débat la parole est aux
orateurs des groupes jacques gauthier
pour le groupe ump
monsieur le premier ministre monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues dans le concert des nations
la france occupe une place particulière
bien au delà de son poids démographique
économique et financier mais notre
histoire et les valeurs que nous portons
ne suffisent plus à justifier les
prérogatives associée à notre statut
international
si aujourd'hui nous conservons une place
de membre permanent du conseil de
sécurité
c'est parce que depuis plus de 50 ans la
france s'est donné les moyens de
disposer d'un outil militaire robuste
polyvalent et autonome qui repose lui
même sur une base industrielle et
technologique de défense puissante et
innovants
cet outil nous confère une grande
liberté d'appréciation une grande
liberté de décision et une grande
liberté d'action
ce sont les princesses de l'indépendance
si aujourd'hui le prix dans la
république pour envoyer des troupes au
mali avec rapidité et efficacité dont
très peu de nations sont capables
c'est parce que ses prédécesseurs tous
ses prédécesseurs depuis le général de
gaulle ont ôté notre pays des l'outil de
défense que nous connaissons long
moderniser et ont veillé à préserver sa
cohérence
en dépit de la réduction constante des
l'effort budgétaire depuis plus de 20
ans si je devais caractériser les
conclusions de la commission du livre
blanc
je dirais tout d'abord que dans ce monde
globalisé les risques et vulnérabilités
n'ont pas diminué par rapport à 2008
bien au contraire face à ces menaces nos
ambitions n'ont pas été réduites
la france entend tenir son rang honoré
ses alliances respecter ces accords et
assurer ses responsabilités aux nations
unies à l'entente aussi défendre ses
intérêts ses approvisionnements les dom
com et contrôler les espaces maritimes
thérèse aériens et spatiaux sur lesquels
s'exerce sa souveraineté le problème est
que face à ces menaces qui augmente et à
ses ambitions qui perdure nos moyens
diminuent au terme d'une série de
confrontations viril où le ministère de
la défense et celui des finances
un jouet un mauvais remake du film
shérif fais moi peur
l'arbitrage final rendu par le président
de la république a permis de sauvegarder
l'essentiel est de maintenir un minimum
de cohérence au format 7 10 ont des
décisions pardon est une décision de bon
sens c'est le moins que la nation
pouvait faire pour honorer le
professionnalisme l'engagement le
dévouement de ceux qui servent nos
couleurs et ont montré une fois de plus
au mali la nécessité pour le droit
d'être soutenu par la force mais encore
faut-il le rappeler
ce résultat est un résultat collectif
il doit beaucoup à vous même monsieur le
ministre de la défense qui avait su
trouver les arguments pour convaincre le
président la république
il doit aussi à la détermination des
industriels de défense qui ont su s'unir
dans l'adversité et faire valoir toute
l'importance de notre pays td ce
résultat découle un peu aussi de la
détermination des parlementaires aussi
bien à l'assemblée nationale qu'au sénat
qui ont su montrer qu'ils n'étaient pas
prêts à sacrifier nos armées je tiens à
remercier et à féliciter le président
jean louis carrère qui veille sur le
consensus bipartisans au sein de sa
commission comme à la prunelle de ses
yeux et qui a su mobiliser l'ensemble
des commissaires sur le seuil de 1.5 de
pipe seuil en dessous duquel l'effort de
défense ne peut pas descendre
le sénat n'est pas le plan de
l'assemblée nationale il est fort quand
il est uni malgré tout ne nous le
cachons pas dire que l'on maintient le
budget en valeur c'est jouer avec les
mots en vérité cela veut dire que ce
budget va diminuer
toutes les années à concurrence de
l'inflation pour autant que l'on puisse
récit mais sur une période aussi longue
cela veut dire que le budget des armées
va perdre entre 10 et 15 milliards
d'euros d'ici 2020 concrètement cela
signifie 24 mille suppressions d'emplois
supplémentaires
cela veut dire de façon pragmatique
qu'il faudra dissoudre cette wii
régiment de l'armée terre ferme et des
bases et des installations de l'armée de
l'air réduire de 25% les équipements de
nos forces ce qui générera le maintien
de matériel plus anciens moins
performants et au frais dans chrétiens
de plus en plus lourd cela signifiera
une diminution des équipements commandés
un étalement des livraisons une
réduction des cibles et un impact direct
sur les industries défense sur l'emploi
cela est d'autant plus probable que
cette équation budgétaire intègre chaque
année plus d'un milliard de ressources
exceptionnels et que sans engagement
fort pour garantir l'effectivité des
ressources budgétaires
toute cette construction demeure à d'une
grande fragilité
or des solutions existent mais nous
savons tous les participations publiques
représentent environ 57 milliards
d'euros
les seules participations dans les
entreprises de défense 12 milliards
d'euros
et encore ce sans compter sans les
entreprises non cotées comme dcns ou
dexter ses participations soyons clairs
ne servent à rien en termes d'utilité
économique
s'il ya bien une leçon à retenir de
l'échec de la fusion du projet avorté
eds berrer c'est bien que la chancelière
allemande a pu plus de poids sans aucune
actions de ads que le président français
qui en détenait pourtant 15%
la cour des comptes vient de montrer des
carences et les failles de l'état
actionnaire de défense
le constat est accablant n'en jetons
plus au moment où la crise n'en finit
pas ces milliards d'euros de
participations seraient plus utilement
consacrée
à l'emploi ok nologie de pointe à la
compétitivité de notre industrie aux
exportations
certes les privations tease à sion sont
un fusil à un coup
mais ce coup de fusil nous donnera le
temps de mettre nos finances en ordre et
de prendre des mesures structurelles de
réduction des déficits sans lesquels
tout efforts seraient vains et toute
souveraineté illusoire pour toutes ces
raisons là que livre blanc est trop
vague et le format d'armes est trop
pauvre par rapport aux possibilités de
la stratégie d'acquisition
l'essentiel sera donc dans la loi de
programmation et dans chacune des lois
de finances qui la mettront à 9
pour faire court et sans à 30 je
voudrais monsieur mise à l'essence vous
livrez saint-prex 7 sur lesquels nous
aurons à coeur de veiller ici au sénat
et en particulier au sein du groupe ump
c'est précèdent sont les suivants la
recherche tu chériras cela se passe de
commentaires tant tout le monde ici est
convaincue de l'utilité de la r&d de
défense l'entraînement tu maintiendra la
force d'une armée réside en grande
partie dans ce l'entraînement là encore
nul besoin de disserter les pièces de
rechange qui commandera par exemple nous
avons acquis 40 hélicoptères tigre à
chapet déjà livrés mais nous n'avions
commandé que des pièces de rechange pour
20 nous l'avons que vers opérationnel
les observe de magasins de pièces de
rechange
vous n'y êtes pour rien dans cette
décision mais il faut éviter qu'elles ne
se répètent monsieur le ministre et nous
attendons 40 tigre hachad et nous vous
demandons dans les négociations avec
l'industriel d'intégrer cette nécessité
de fournir des pièces de rechange
même s'il faut au final réduire un peu
la cible mais accroître la disponibilité
des matériels quatrième préceptes les
grands programmes en coopération il
maintiendra ce qui est l'un des
engagements du code de conduite de
l'agencé européenne de défense
le premier a400m dont l'absence nous a
cruellement fait défaut au mali vol sous
les couleurs tricolores et les trois
premiers devront être livrés avant la
fin de cette année sur la commande de ce
un conte appareils 35 devrait arriver
dans les forces avant 2027 si nous
voulons vraiment faire des économies sur
ce programme alors fixons nous comme
objectif prioritaire de convaincre nos
partenaires de mettre en commun les
pièces de rechange et de faire du
bowling schering dans le soutien cela
est d'autant plus important qu'en
matière aéronautique pour un euro
dépensé dans l'équipement il faut
dépenser 2 euros dans le soutien 5e
pressaient les lacunes qui comblera ou
du mois tu essaieras le transportait tj
étatique j'allais parler le
ravitaillement en vol vous le connaissez
le renseignement avec des drones male à
settat gars vous savez que je salue
votre décision d'acheter des drones
reaper mais vous devez préparer l'avenir
il faut penser aux 30 de troisième
génération au niveau européen
de même que vous devez encourager
l'étape suivante celle de luca le drone
de combat et reese en 2030
donc un démonstrateur je le rappelle
construit par un consortium emmené par
dassault a déjà volé
je sais que sur ce point nous sommes
l'harmonie monsieur le ministre d'après
votre aveu vous n'avez fait que suivre
les recommandations énoncées par notre
assemblée ce qui m'amènerait presque à
formuler un sixième préceptes le sénat
tu gagneras écoutez je conclus ici vous
l'avez compris monsieur le ministre
le groupe ump du sénat à la volonté de
soutenir l'effort de défense de la
france et nous sommes prêts si vous
l'acceptez à nous investir sans réserve
mais sans reniement à vos côtés pour que
cette loi de programmation militaire
malgré ses limites budgétaires soit la
meilleure possible pour nos armées
notre recherche mais industrie nous le
devons aux hommes et aux femmes qui
défendent le territoire notre population
et nous intégrer dans le monde et dans
l'engagement au service de notre pays
n'a jamais fini si le gouvernement
travaille dans ce sens monsieur le
ministre vous nous trouverez à vos côtés
si vous deviez faire du budget de la
défense une variable d'ajustement
nous serions vaut plus farouches
opposants je vous remercie
merci la parole à monsieur jacques
berthou pour le groupe socialiste
e
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes
supposées dans la commission mes chers
collègues tout est informatique
tout est numérique l'informatisation de
notre société est une réalité en très
peu de temps
en une vingtaine d'années
l'accroissement exponentiel des
nouvelles technologies de l'information
des communications ont complètement
bouleversé nos relations humaines
économiques industrielles ce monde
numérique est en constante mutation et
génère de nouveaux comportements
la convergence des moyens des réseaux
permettent des connexions aux multiples
ramifications
mais aux avantages prouver les dangers
sont bien réels la généralisation
croissante de cette technologie
indispensable à l'accroissement de nos
sociétés les rend d'autant plus
vulnérables
chaque jour ce sont des millions d'
attaque qui perturbe et polluent les
systèmes informatiques les plus divers
et pour des raisons très différentes
recherches d'informations espionnage
propagande est plus préoccupant la
perturbation des systèmes informatiques
ou l'interruption de leur fonctionnement
je citerai pour mémoire qu'ici même le
sénat avait subi une attaque entre 6
heures du matin le dimanche 25 décembre
et le lundi 26 décembre dans
l'après-midi par saturation de l'accès
internet
si cela n'a pas eu de conséquences
néfastes
il en serait tout autrement si des
attaques ciblaient nos systèmes de
défense est pertubé perturbé
l'efficacité opérationnelle des forces
en opération en attaquant les systèmes
d'information et de communication en
modifiant tous les paramètres des
systèmes d'armes et plates formes de
combat
les conséquences seraient
catastrophiques cette menace existe elle
était prise en considération dans le
livre blanc de 2008 mais en très peu
d'années
l'évolution des situations
internationales
la complexité et les capacités des
systèmes
composant le cyberespace nous oblige à
nous adapter à ces nouvelles exigences
le livre blanc celui que vous nous
proposez monsieur le ministre prend bien
en compte ces préoccupations
il adapte et amplifie les préconisations
du livre blanc de 2008
la constante évolution de notre
dépendance à cet univers qui est celui
du cyber espace met en péril si nous ne
prenons pas à sa juste dimension
ce véritable danger notre souveraineté
et toute notre économie
si nous subissions une attaque de grande
envergure
le sénat a pris en compte ce danger
puisque à l'initiative de monsieur jean
louis carrère président de la commission
des affaires étrangères de la défense et
des forces armées
deux rapports ont été publiés sur ce
sujet celui de monsieur jean-marie
bockel la cyberdéfense un enjeu mondial
une priorité nationale et celui que je
co signé avec jean marie bockel sécurité
des réseaux de l'information dans
l'union et stratégie européenne de
sécurité
le colloque qui s'est tenu au sénat le
16 mai sur le thème quelles perspectives
après le livre blanc organisaient des
débats sur les grands enjeux auxquels
nous devons faire face l'état de la
menace et la stratégie de réponse
nationale
la coopération européenne et
internationale et quelle politique
industrielle pour la cyberdéfense et la
cyber sécurité
si la diversité des thèmes a permis de
bien mesurer l'ampleur des risques
les débats qui ont suivi ont mis en
évidence toutes les actions pour
lesquelles nous devrons nous engager
vous le dit monsieur le ministre
le cyber des falaises cyberespace est
désormais un champ de confrontation à
part entière et nécessitera vous le
préciser que nous ne nous donne que nous
nous donnions les moyens nécessaires à
notre capacité de production à ceux de
notre souveraineté
au renforcement des moyens humains au
soutien des compétences scientifiques et
technologiques à l'autonomie de la
production de nos dispositifs de
sécurité au développement de notre
industrie nationale à la définition d'un
dispositif législatif définissant les
standards de sécurité tout en
poursuivant nos relations avec nos
partenaires privilégiés que sont tout
d'abord le royaume uni et l'allemagne
mais déjà et sans attendre notre défense
s'est adaptée aux enjeux que sont qui
sont de sa responsabilité en créant une
chaîne de commandement interarmées
ministériel placé sous l'autorité du
chef d'état major des armées est chargée
d'organiser et de conduire l'ensemble de
la défense des systèmes d'information la
formation du personnel celles des
spécialistes d'ingénieurs formés à la
cyberdéfense complétera nos capacités de
défense au même titre comme le souhaite
l'état major des armées
en raison de la de l'interaction entre
la cyberdéfense de l'armée et du civil
que soit mis en place un réseau de
réservistes spécialisés dans ce domaine
et cela dans le cadre de la réserve
citoyenne
j'ajouterai que le développement de la
cyberdéfense est également une chance
pour nos industries avoir la maîtrise de
certaines technologies fondamentales
dans des domaines variés comme la
cryptologie et la production de certains
équipements de sécurité ou de détection
peut générer des milliers d'emplois et
ainsi participer au redressement de
notre appareil productif
cette politique industrielle
volontariste est susceptible de
concerner la france et plus globalement
l'ensemble des états de l'union
européenne
il s'agit parallèlement de développer
l'activité du renseignement dans ce
domaine et les capacités techniques
correspondantes
le livre blanc sur la défense et la
sécurité nationale qui fait de la
cyberdéfense lune
les clés de la défense du futur nous
pauvres que nous avons parfaitement
compris les évolutions liées à ce
nouveau type d'attaqué est ce que je
salue nos ambitions en la matière sont
parfaitement résumé en page 94 le
développement de capacités de cyber
défense militaire fera l'objet d'un
effort marqué en relation étroite avec
le domaine du renseignement
la france développera sa posture sur la
base d'une organisation de cyberdéfense
étroitement intégrés aux forces
disposant de capacités défensives et
offensives pour préparer ou accompagner
les opérations militaires
je n'en doute pas monsieur le ministre
nous puissions y parvenir
et c'est bien pour la raison pour
laquelle avec l'ensemble du groupe
socialiste nous approuvons japon toutes
les dispositions contenues dans le livre
blanc que vous nous proposez
merci la parole à madame michelle
demessine pour le groupe crc
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des affaires étrangères et de
la défense
conformément à la constitution
vous avez exposé les grandes lignes de
notre stratégie de défense et de
sécurité nationale qui fait l'objet du
nouveau livre blanc remis au président
de la république
celui ci l'a approuvée le 29 février
dernier à l'occasion de la présentation
que vous en faites devant nos deux
assemblées parlementaires les
différentes forces politiques ont ainsi
la possibilité d'exprimer publiquement
leur appréciation et leurs analyses sur
ces questions essentielles pour l'avenir
de notre pays
nous félicitons de cette séance car les
possibilités de débattre publiquement de
ces sujets sont rares ceux ci j'aime à
le rappeler a qu à cause d'institutions
qui n'associe pas le parlement à la
définition de la politique de défense et
de sécurité de la nation et qui donc
limite considérablement le contrôle
parlementaire sur l'action
gouvernementale dans ce domaine je
déplore d'ailleurs que nous ayons eue
vendredi dernier un un nouvel exemple de
cette pratique qui négligent ce domaine
le rôle de la représentation nationale
avec l'exposé fait sur ces questions par
le président de la république à
l'institut des hautes études de la
défense nationale devant un prestigieux
auditoire et cela avant même notre débat
j'apprécie donc d'autant plus que le
chef de l'état se soit engagé à
renforcer le droit de regard et
d'information du parlement concernant
nos opérations extérieures les
exportations d'armement et le
renseignement
ceci étant dit depuis le livre blanc
publié en 2008 les yeux vo lu tion
géopolitique du monde la crise
économique et financière et l'état de
nos finances publiques
rand est absolument nécessaire une
nouvelle réflexion sur notre politique
de défense et de sécurité
pour autant cette réflexion et l
réellement nouvelle je ne le pense pas
car sur le fond elle s'inscrit dans une
continuité idéologique avec le pouvoir
précédent la crise budgétaire en plus
auparavant je voudrais nerfs moi dire
que l'un des mérites de ce document
outre la grande qualité de ses analyses
et devait reçue malgré tout adapté avec
habileté les ambitions de la france dans
le monde à la réalité de nos moyens
ceci dit ceci sans baisser la garde sur
notre sécurité notamment en maintenant
l'effort budgétaire à 31,4 milliards
d'euros annuels pour rester s'était dit
avant moi une puissance crédible ni
transiger sur la défense et la promotion
de nos principes et de nos valeurs
ainsi l'heure n'est plus comme
précédemment à la modernisation tout
azimut vanté dans le livre blanc de 2008
mais non financé ni à la polyvalence des
équipements mais cela se fait au prix
d'une nouvelle suppression de 24 mille
postes soit environ 10% de nos forces et
d'un étalement de crédit attribuée à nos
programmes d'armement avec toutes les
inquiétudes que nous pouvons avoir sur
les emplois tout ceci impliquant une
révision drastique du contrat
opérationnel fixé à nos armées l'armée
de terre en particulier certes une
certaine continue était nécessaire dans
ce domaine et il est possible de
partager entre sensibilités politiques
différentes
quelques principes fondamentaux sur la
défense nationale
mais je regrette qu'en fonction de ce
que signifiait le résultat de l'élection
présidentielle de 2012
vous nous fassiez monsieur le ministre
une présentation de ce document qui ne
nous donne pas une vision différente de
l'état du monde et du rôle de notre pays
alors qu'il aurait fallu alors qu'il
aurait dû donner une nouvelle vision
stratégique de la france dans le monde
à nouveau la réflexion a été soumise à
la contrainte budgétaire
ainsi après plus de neuf mois de
laborieux travaux aucune des grandes
orientations stratégiques
définie par le précédent chef de l'état
et les forces politiques qui le
soutenait ne sont remises en cause
je crains d'ailleurs que les arbitrages
politiques sur ces questions est tout
simplement été rendu avant la
publication du document le président de
la commission du livre blanc à
d'ailleurs lui-même reconnu que sa vie
version initiale avait été entièrement
réécrite par le ministère de la défense
vous avez procédé comme auparavant en
tentant de mettre en cohérence ses
missions et les moyens de nos forces de
définir un format d'armé et un contrat
opérationnel en ayant toujours à
l'esprit la contrainte budgétaire
il était donc difficile dans ces
conditions d'aboutir à un réel travail
d'élaboration conceptuel est ce vraiment
ainsi dans la direction d'une réduction
de certaines de nos capacités de nos
moyens qu'il faut s'orienter pour nous
adapter à la nouvelle situation
géostratégique
à l'heure où tout le monde s'accorde à
reconnaître que les menaces sont
diffusés multiforme que la résolution
des comptes des conflits conventionnels
a changé de nature
est il pertinent de continuer à prôner
une nouvelle réduction des effectifs et
du format de nos armées dans les
conflits d'aujourd'hui et la gestion des
crises
l'expérience le montre les forces
terrestres sont primordiales
elles ont besoin de capacités de
projection aériennes et navales efficace
or alors que le retrait accéléré de
l'aghanistan et l'accent mis sur la
recherche de la légitimité des nations
unies pouvaient laisser croire qu'une
nouvelle doctrine moins
interventionniste et plus prudentes
allez voir le jour en matière
d'intervention extérieure
ce sujet n'est pas véritablement traité
dans le livre blanc mais en revanche à
doctrine constante le contrat
opérationnel de l'armée de terre qui
doit lui permettre d'envoyer des hommes
et des équipements en urgence sur un ou
plusieurs théâtres d'opérations
extérieures pendant plusieurs mois
écart quasiment divisé par deux passant
de 30 milles à 15000 hommes
nous nous apprêtons à prendre le chemin
inverse en réduisant leur format en
prévoyant de n'assurer que trop
lentement
le renouvellement de matériel parfois à
bout de souffle il y a là un paradoxe et
un manque de cohérence
certes les moyens attribués aux
renseignements
les fonctions de connaissance et
anticipation seront très fortement
augmenté
nous serons peut-être mieux renseignés
mais je maintiens que les mesures de
réduction amoindriront nos capacités
d'intervention et de gestion des crises
je constate avec regret que décision qui
aurait pu légitimement modifier ou
infléchir les grandes orientations
stratégiques président précédentes n'ont
pas été prises et je me limiterai à
trois domaines qui aurait dû être
marquée par un net changement
d'orientation
ainsi je regrette qu'en fonction de
l'analyse qui est faite des risques et
des menaces auxquels le pays doit faire
face et qui continue à se diversifier
le concept de sécurité nationale ait été
maintenu
j'entends bien que dans ce monde
globalisé la notion de défense au sens
militaire du terme ne recouvre plus
exclusivement la défense du territoire
national et que la sécurité ne commence
pas à nos frontières mais cela
justifit-il que l'on étende à ce point
le périmètre de la défense
cet amalgame de deux notions qui restent
différentes
cette tendance au tout sécuritaire dans
nos sociétés me semble dangereux en
particulier pour les libertés publiques
et individuelles
ce concept de sécurité globale risque
par exemple d'opérer aussi un amalgame
entre des menaces à la sécurité délai de
l'état et d'éventuelles crises sociales
nous l'avions déjà dit en 2008
pour ce qui est des risques et des
menaces elles ne sont pas rayer rares
chis et de façon suffisamment précise
puisque on englobe tout à la fois la
prolifération nucléaire les attentats
terroristes les attaques informatiques
les tensions nées de l'accès aux
ressources ou bien encore les pandémies
et autres catastrophes naturelles ainsi
parmi l'analyse des menaces celle
attribuée à la faiblesse des états le
constat est précis mais les causes
réelles sont mal identifiées
ce qui fait que les solutions
essentiellement sécuritaire et militaire
proposée pour répondre à ce type de
menace ne se donne pas les moyens de
s'attaquer aux raisons profondes des
tensions et des crises traiter ces
phénomènes sous un angle essentiellement
sécuritaire comme le fait le livre blanc
ne peut que contribuer à les exacerber
sur ces questions de sécurité les
conséquences positives de notre
intervention au mali semblait pourtant
indiqué notre attention et notre volonté
d'accorder désormais la priorité au
développement économique sur nos
interventions militaires mais j'estime
que dans son discours tenu à addis abeba
à l'occasion des célébrations du
cinquantenaire les cinquantenaires de
l'union africaine le président de la
république sont sans doute encore sous
le choc des récents attentats
terroristes au niger n'a pas
suffisamment affirmé cette orientation
nouvelle concernant la dissuasion
nucléaire
je regrette qu'il n'y ait pas eu non
plus à renouvellement de la réflexion
sur ce sujet là aussi on assiste dans la
continuité d'une doctrine qui fonctionne
sur des dogmes qui paraissent intangible
vous avez manqué l'occasion d'un grand
débat national sur cette question dont
il n'est pas du tout évident qu'elle
fasse l'objet d'un consensus national
aussi profond qu auparavant
plutôt que de vouloir conserver en
l'état à notre arsenal nucléaire
avec ces deux composantes maritime et
aéroportée il aurait fallu s'interroger
sur sa pertinence pour lutter
aujourd'hui contre des menaces qui ne
proviennent plus principalement d'état
en tant que tel sur nos intérêts vitaux
cette notion d' intérêts vitaux de la
nation mérite et mériterait également
d'être précisée afin de vérifier qu'elle
est vraiment partagé par tous par
ailleurs son coût financier est
considérable
il représente un quart du budget global
de la défense si l'on englobe les
équipements nécessaires à sa mise en
oeuvre et il est ainsi maintenu en
réduisant les moyens de nos forces
conditions conventionnel qui sont
pourtant indispensable à la crédibilité
des forces nucléaires
la modernisation et les développements
de notre outil nucléaires sont en outre
quoique on
eandis contraire aux principes affirmés
de stricte suffisance
nous l'avons déjà dit et nous leur
disons aujourd'hui c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous estimons que notre pays ne
s'engagent pas assez résolument dans la
lutte contre la prolifération nucléaire
et qu'il ne s'abîme satisfait pas tous
les engagements pris dans le cadre du
traité de non-prolifération en matière
de désarmement
on peut même penser que nous ne sommes
plus dans le cadre de la stricte
suffisance et qu'il contredit ses
engagements en modernisant et
développant nos armes nucléaires enfin
et dernier point concernant nos
alliances et l'otan je déplore que le
livre blanc la suite de notre retour
dans le commandement militaire intégré
propose y rester pour consolider notre
place au sein de l'organisation
nous avions pourtant ensemble à gauche
d'ailleurs critiqué cette décision de
nicolas sarkozy au prétexte que par
alignement sur la politique étrangère
des états unis
elle risquait de nous faire perdre de
notre autonomie stratégique et d'entrer
en contradiction avec la nécessité de
construire une véritable europe de la
défense
il semble que le rapport d'évaluation
commandé à hubert védrine qui concluait
prudemment qu'il était urgent de ne rien
changer et largement inspiré l'analyse
de cette question pour notre part nous
continuons de penser que malgré le
recentrage stratégique des états unis
des états unis sur l'asie l'organisation
militaire de l'alliance atlantique reste
trop étroitement dépendante des intérêts
américains
c'est aussi parce que plusieurs pays
européens se repose sur cette
organisation pour leur sécurité et qui
se refuse à y consacrer un effort
important que l'on comprend mieux toutes
leurs réticences envers des initiatives
en matière de programmes d'armement ou
de partage et de mutualisation de leurs
capacités militaires
le livre blanc malgré ces attentions
malgré des intentions louables semble
trop facilement s'accommoder de cette
situation il y à un renoncement
implicite à l'ambition d'une europe de
la défense et l'acceptation d'une france
qui serait une puissance moyenne trop
étroitement lié aux états unis notre
pays doit jouer un rôle d'entraînement
en pour relancer la politique européenne
de défense et de sécurité
sinon l'europe continuera d'être intégré
à la partie de domino que jouent les
états unis dans le monde
nous souhaitons au contraire que l'union
européenne qui représente un quart des
richesses de la planète et john holmes
et dont nous sommes l'un des éléments
moteurs met tout son poids dans la
résolution pacifique des comptes des
conflits dans le respect du droit
international et des résolutions de
l'onu
tels sont le ciel ministre les
principales appréciation sur les
orientations de la politique de défense
et de sécurité nationale dans le groupe
communiste citoyens et république a
souhaité vous faire part merci de votre
attention
merci la parole à jean marie bockel pour
le groupe ou des iut
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues ne nous y trompons pas les
français sont attachés à leur armée et
les questions de défense ne doivent pas
être absente du débat public
en tant que parlementaire nous avons
raison de contribuer à cette réflexion
et ce débat est d'autant plus important
que le livre blanc a suscité de très
fortes inquiétudes surtout avant sa
parution il faut bien le dire en effet
alors que d'autres doc a évoqué lors de
son élaboration
la possibilité d'un scénario catastrophe
10 aides conduisant à des coupes
budgétaires drastiques
la plupart des groupes politiques du
sénat à l'initiative d'ailleurs de la
commission des affaires étrangères la
défense et des forces armées de son pub
nas président jean louis carrère s'est
clairement exprimée en faveur du
maintien d'un effort de défense de -1 5%
de son pib en juger par les propos du
président de la république sur notre
politique de défense
il semble finalement que notre appel ne
soient pas restés vains je dis bien il
semble car au delà des annonces
il faudra désormais attendre la
prochaine loi de programmation militaire
2014 2019 pour connaître avec plus de
précision les arbitrages budgétaires
le livre blanc n'est donc qu'une
première étape et nous ne manquerons pas
de suivre avec attention les futures
dispositions de la loi de programmation
pour nous assurer que la défense ne
devienne pas une variable d'ajustement
cinq ans après la publication du livre
blanc de 2008
l'objectif assigné par le président de
la république à la commission chargée de
préparer et est de redéfinir la
stratégie de la france en matière de
défense et de sécurité nationale à la
lumière des récentes évolutions du monde
cet objectif at il été atteint
la france est elle en mesure d'assurer
la cohérence générale de ses armées
ainsi que son influence sur la scène
internationale
il est encore trop tôt pour répondre
franchement à ces questions mais
quelques remarques s'imposent dès à
présent le livre blanc confirme en
premier lieu la persistance de menaces
diverses y compris nouvelles auxquelles
notre pays doit faire face
qu'il s'agisse de la prolifération des
armes de destruction massive massive du
terrorisme ou des risques posés par les
états faillis ou voyou nul doute que le
monde d'aujourd'hui
et aussi instable incertain après
visible qui ne l'était hier voire même
plus si le risque d'un conflit militaire
entre états n'a pas disparu en témoigne
l'augmentation partout dans le monde des
budgets de défense
nous devons constater le développement
de nouvelles menaces multiformes à
l'image des cyberattaques nous en
reparlerons je ne souhaite pas m'étendre
davantage sur l'analyse géopolitique
faite par le livre blanc qui se révèle
d'ailleurs sur certains points plus
descriptif que prospectifs
globalement le panorama des menaces est
partagé par l'ensemble des observateurs
mais qu'en est il des mécanismes de
réponse proposée par le livre blanc
peuvent ils permettre à la france de
dépasser son horizon stratégique pour
conserver sa place de puissance
régionale à rayonnement mondial et
d'assurer son rang dans les instances
internationales de paix et de sécurité
il y as nous l'avons beaucoup d'entre
nous le constate il ya une attente de
france un peu partout dans le monde et
répondre à cette attente est pour nous
non seulement un devoir mais également
un vecteur d'influencé et donc de
défense de nos intérêts légitimes
le livre blanc évoque plus
particulièrement trois fonctions
prioritaires qui doivent structurer
l'action de forces armées d'abord la
protection de nos compatriotes et de
notre territoire
il force les armes et ainsi conforter
leur rôle de sécurité intérieure et de
sécurité civile en cas de crise majeure
pourquoi d'ailleurs ne pas ouvrir une
réflexion sur cette dimension en
définissant peut-être une approche plus
globale et intégrée de la sécurité
intérieure intégrant les armées mais pas
seulement
et cela évidemment sans tabou
deuxièmement la dissuasion nucléaire et
réaffirmé comme protection ultime de
notre pays concernant des agressions qui
toucherait ses intérêts vitaux
même si la france reste un état doté de
l'armé nucléaire elle entend maintenir
son arsenal à un niveau de stricte
suffisante
cette sanctuarisation de notre force
nucléaire assurant l'état la permanence
de notre posture de dissuasion enfin la
france souhaite conserver toute sa
capacité d'intervention aussi bien pour
protéger ses ressortissants à l'étranger
que prendre part et somme de l'actualité
des opérations multilatérale dans le
cadre de ses engagements internationaux
cette capacité de projection est un
formidable outil au service de notre
diplomatie qui ne restera cependant
pertinente
si elle est dotée de moyens adéquats et
dimensionné et à cet égard
l'impact de l'opération militaire
française au mali a était pour beaucoup
je crois une prise de conscience cette
intervention a démontré la nécessité
pour notre pays de disposer d'une force
de réaction rapide en cas de crise
majeure
l'utilité des troupes prépositionné qui
étaient remises en cause il ya peu pour
des raisons budgétaires les uns et les
autres a également été validé dans
quelle mesure en effet la france
aurait-elle pu répondre à la percée des
forces djihadistes d'art bamako sans la
présence de forces françaises au plus
près de la ligne de fond dans un premier
temps forces spéciales du dispositif
sabre et ensuite les forces
prépositionnées classique en tout cas
merci monsieur le ministre de votre
disponibilité permanente pour notre
commission de votre écoute et plus
généralement pour votre engagement
l'opération serval a par ailleurs
conduit un certain retour de l'afrique
en tant que région stratégique de
première importance
tout du moins dans les mentalités après
dix années d'afghanistan compte tenu des
menaces qui persistent dans la zone
sahélo-saharienne la corne de l'afrique
où le golfe de guinée et qui affecte
directement la sécurité européenne notre
sécurité
l'afrique doit être considérée comme une
zone d'intérêt prioritaire pas seulement
d'ailleurs sur le plan sécuritaire
ces questions de sécurité majeure en
afrique se pose à un moment où il ya un
retour de l'afrique plus généralement
notamment en matière d'économie de
croissance et de développement
en tout cas s'agissant de l'enjeu africa
les bases françaises en afrique reste
des points d'appui essentiel qu'il
conviendra de maintenir voire de
renforcer ou de faire évoluer en tout
cas d'adapter en tout cas la question
est clairement posée dans sa chacun de
ces domaines protection dissuasion
intervention l'action de la france est
indissociable d'une capacité de
connaissances et d'anticipation
consolider les récentes opérations
extérieures nous ont rappelé nos
faiblesses en matière de renseignement
de développement d'une capacité
d'appréciation autonome c'est un élément
d'indépendance et cela est indispensable
au delà de l'apport éventuel est utile
de nos alliés bien sûr si le livre blanc
met l'accent sur cet aspect je
m'interroge monsieur luminus sur la mise
en oeuvre concrète de cette orientation
alors où le mystère la défense s'apprête
à réduire ces
ces effectifs quels services
bénéficieront réellement de ce
renforcement dans un monde c'est
imprévisible l'action de la france ne
peut se concevoir indépendamment de
celle de nos principaux partenaires en
particulier au sein de l'alliance
atlantique
le retour de la france dans le
commandement intégré n'est pas remise en
cause comme le confirme le livre blanc
c'est bien mais il devrait s'accompagner
d'un questionnement sur la place de la
france au sein de l'otan
notre pays semble réticent parfois à
déployer une véritable stratégie au sein
des structures où nous prenons place à
l'instar de nos alliés anglo saxons il
ne s'agissait nullement de profiter de
certains commandements nous avons
d'ailleurs des chefs de grande valeur
pour défendre une approche purement
nationale mais bien de faire valoir
notre culture stratégique dans le
respect de notre engagement collectif
cette question pourrait être débattue
d'ailleurs sans esprit polémique
l'union européenne est un échelon bien
sûr essentielle pour inscrire notre
action et à l'heure où de plus en plus
nous devrons compter sur nous-mêmes
européen pour notre sécurité notre
voisinage
c'est une véritable stratégie européenne
en matière de défense peine à trouver
une traduction concrète dans les faits
les contraintes budgétaires devraient
encourager les pays européens à
développer leur coopération dans ce
domaine il ya des domaines qui relèvent
de la souveraineté nationale et de dave
qui peuvent relever d'une souveraineté
partagée des mécanismes existent pour
les pays le souhaitant je pense à des
coopérations renforcées prévue par le
traité lisbonne et non utilisées la
france qui est exprimé par la voix du
président de la république la semaine
dernière sa volonté de relancer l'europe
de la défense
et c'est bien auraient-elles des
propositions concrètes a formulées
notamment au vu en vue du conseil de
décembre nous l'espérons car le livre
blanc restent floues en la matière la
rédaction d'un véritable livre blanc
européen définissant des intérêts
stratégiques de l'union européenne
aurait aujourd'hui tout son sens pour
mettre en oeuvre notre stratégie le
format des armées est une question
centrale beaucoup l'ont dit je ne vais
pas rappeler les chiffres mais de
réduction en plus des réductions déjà
engagées ou en cours mais les
conséquences d'une réforme à caractère
purement comptable ni en la cohérence de
nos besoins
je ne dis pas que c'est le cas mais si
c'était le cas ce serait dramatique
ainsi pourriez-vous d'ores et déjà
monsieur le ministre nous apporter des
garanties quant à la préservation de nos
forces opérationnelles dont le nombre
est déjà fortement limité pour remplir
le spectre de ses missions de quelle
manière cette réduction sera t-elle
opérer alors que vous êtes pourtant
favorable à la civilisation des missions
de soutien
c'est bien ces postes-là qui sont dans
le collimateur qui peuvent être
variables d'ajustement je suis je saisis
également cette occasion pour aborder
dire un mot sur la question de la
réserve qui me paraît trop identifié
comme un vivier de spécialistes ce qui
est bien dans le livre blanc
alors qu'elle est aussi elle devrait
être de plus en plus une composante
majeure de notre outil de défense c'est
le cas déjà de beaucoup d'armes et en
europe ou ailleurs dans un contexte
budgétaire particulièrement rude
pourquoi ne pas recruter et former des
réservistes opérationnels pour pallier
la baisse des effectifs sans oublier
d'ailleurs le rôle de plus en plus utile
notamment en matière de cyber de la
défense citoyenne il est bon de rappeler
que cette réserve participe grandement à
la compréhension par la nation de ses
forces armées
le lien armée nation comme l'a souligné
le président ali hached et n est fait
écho au concept de sécurité globale et
de résilience au coeur même du livre
blanc concernant les aspects capacitaire
que beaucoup de collègues ont déjà
évoqué le livre blanc maintient les
grands programmes d'équipement des
forces armées même si l'acte une
réduction des quantités a commandé mes
chers collègues n'oublions pas que
l'industrie de défense
tous y compris le premier ministre m'ont
soumier tout à l'heure est garante de
notre indépendance stratégique elle est
également porteuse d'emplois et
contribue au dynamisme de notre économie
et au rétablissement notre balance
extérieure via les exportations
c'est en somme appuyée essentiel de
notre politique de défense condition
sinequanone de notre autonomie
stratégique
si l'éventualité d'une commande publique
amoindri ne peut être écartée compte
tenu des efforts budgétaires nécessaires
des pistes de réflexion sont toutefois
envisageables notamment les là aussi à
l'échelle européenne le renforcement de
la base technologique et industrielle de
l'europe dans ce domaine devrait être
une priorité
de par sa dimension stratégique mais
également ses potentialités économiques
ainsi alors que la france s'apprête à
acquérir une capacité de drones
métro est à gérer je comprends qu'on
puisse faire autrement
cela s'explique tout de même par un
manque cruel de moyens de reconnaissance
et de surveillance
mais quid des projets européens en la
matière pour ne prendre que cet exemple
pour terminer je voudrais également
saluer après mon collègue jacques
berthou avec lequel effectivement nous
travaillons en ce moment sur la
dimension européenne d'une politique de
cyber sécurité y compris dans ses
composantes industrielles de
potentialités industrielles voit donc
saluer les dispositions du livre blanc
qu en matière de cyberdéfense et là
j'aurais vraiment me réjouir de voir que
un certain nombre de mesures avancées
répondre directement aux préconisations
que dans le cadre de notre commission
des affaires étrangères et de la défense
que nous avons effectivement proposé de
manière extrêmement claire et d'ailleurs
de manière unanime le livre blanc
consacré le renforcement des moyens
humains dédiés à la cyber défense en
particulier au sein de l'appareil d'état
des armées afin d'atteindre un niveau
comparable à nos partenaires
britanniques et allemands et dans ce
domaine là croyez le bien
ce qu'on fait on le fait très bien on
n'a pas à rougir on n'a pas à avoir de
complexes mais nous devons poursuivre
l'effort et le livre blanc le dit
l'accent est également mis sur la
dimension industrielle ainsi que sur la
capacité de résilience des opérateurs
d'importance vitale si le livre blanc
constitue une étape importante vers une
meilleure prise en compte des enjeux
liés à la sécurité et à la protection
des systèmes d'information et là aussi
le premier ministre l'a rappelé tout à
l'heure il est désormais urgent d'agir
sur la mise en oeuvre de ces dispositifs
notamment au travers d'un certain nombre
à côté des moyens financiers humains
ça tombe d'évolutions législatives et
réglementaires qu'on ait eu l'occasion
dé à de développer dans nos travaux des
efforts ont été entrepris depuis 2008
depuis le précédent livre blanc nous
sommes aujourd'hui je le dis souvent au
milieu du gué et nous devons donc
continuer à rattraper notre retard
progressivement le livre blanc indique
le chemin
nous allons donc je l'espère le suivre
jusqu'au bout avec ce livre blanc la
france est elle en mesure de faire face
à son environnement stratégie qui à
tenir son rang sur la scène
internationale
certes la publication du livre blanc a
permis de réaffirmer notre stratégie en
matière de défense et de sécurité autour
des grandes priorités que je rappeler
tout à l'heure cette stratégie est
plutôt conforme aux ambitions de notre
pays
même si elle semble parfois manquer
d'une vision à long terme mais plus
généralement quelle est la principale
rupture de ce livre blanc
elle est selon moi d'ordre économique et
financier aussi bien d'ailleurs que
géopolitique
la france est devant des choix
budgétaires difficiles et les armes et
ne pourront s'y soustraire nous le
savons nous devons néanmoins pas
sacrifier aux seules économies court
terme notre savoir faire en matière de
défense
surtout que toute capacité perdu
aujourd'hui le serait définitivement le
risque est ainsi de ne plus avoir les
moyens de nos ambitions et c'est donc
bien la future loi de programmation
militaire que nous attendons cassel qui
traduira en termes de budget vous le
savez les arbitrages en matière
d'effectifs et de matériel en définitive
ne pourront jusque-là juger de l'impact
serait livre blanc sur les armées
françaises tout en gardant à l'esprit
que ce cadre budgétaire doit servir la
stratégie et non l inverse
vous pouvez être assuré monsieur le
ministre que le groupe udi us et sera un
partenaire vigilant constructif mais
vigilant lors de l'examen de cette loi
de programmation militaire
un des enjeux majeurs de celle ci sera
de tenir compte de notre réalité aussi
bien stratégique que budgétaire même si
la défense entend participer à l'effort
de redressement budgétaire comme elle
l'a toujours fait cette contribution ne
doit pas être ni plus ni moins
importante que celle des autres
ministères il en va de la pérennité de
notre outil de défense de la poursuite
de nos ambitions sur la scène
internationale et in fine et de
l'indépendance stratégie de notre pays
merci la parole est à présent à jean
michel baylet pour le groupe rds c'est
le président monsieur le ministre
monsieur le ministre ce prix à la
commission
mes chers collègues l'élaboration d'un
livre dans la défense et de la sécurité
nationale et toujours par nature un
exercice complexe
il s'agit en effet de concilier
prospective à long terme et monde en
perpétuel bouleversement impératifs
militaires et contraintes budgétaires à
ce jour nos forces sont engagés au mali
côte d'ivoire au tchad au liban dans
l'océan indien contre les actes de
piraterie ou encore en afghanistan et je
souhaite rendre ici hommage à l'art
efficacité à leur dévouement et leur
action
c'est également un des militaires qu'il
revient d'assurer la protection de notre
territoire dans le cadre du plan
vigipirate et la violente agression dont
a été victime un soldat lors d'une
patrouille à quelques jours fin de
semaine dernière est venu nous le
rappeler je souhaite d'ailleurs à mon
nom mais je les imagine on en donne en
somme notre assemblée exprimé aux
premières classes cédric cordier toute
notre solidarité et nos voeux de prompt
rétablissement et chers collègues la
rédaction d'un livre blanc à peine cinq
années après le précédent se justifie
également regard des perspectives en
termes de finances publiques et de
redressement des comptes de l'état dès
dans son bilan à mi parcours de la
dernière loi de programmation
la cour des comptes souligné que la
programmation budgétaire pour les années
2009 2014 avait pêché par excès
d'optimisme
certaines hypothèses n'ayant pas fait
l'oeuvre disaient leur cour des comptes
est la preuve de réalisme suffisant et
donc cette dernière recommandé la mise à
jour du livre
il importe donc que la future loi de
programmation ne cède pas elle à son
tour à la tentation de l'incantatoire et
je formule le voeu monsieur me de la
défense que le sénat soit pleinement
associés à la rédaction de la future
l'opération militaire qui sera débattu à
l'automne
cela concrétise hre a d'ailleurs la
volonté exprimée par le prennent la
république de renforcer les prérogatives
du parlement car les sénateurs ont
encore en mémoire la façon dont s'était
déroulé les débats en 2009
cette manière n'avait pas recueilli leur
assentiment
ce quatrième livre blanc trace donc les
grandes orientations de notre politique
de défense et de sécurité
le premier ministre nous les a exposés
tout à l'heure une question une question
subsiste cependant le scénario retenu
pourra-t-il permettre à la france de
conserver son rang
si le prends la république a annoncé que
tous les programmes militaires seraient
maintenus il semble néanmoins difficile
au vu des contraintes budgétaires de ne
pas en état les certaine dans le temps
et sachant qu il importe aussi de
soutenir nos industries de pointe
quel choix stratégiques sont en fait
monsieur le ministre
par ailleurs vous le savez
l'annnonce de la suppression de 24 mille
emplois supplémentaires suscite des
inquiétudes quant aux capacités de
projection des troupes mais aussi quant
à l'évolution de la présence militaire
sur notre territoire
s'il est bien sûr encore trop tôt pour
établir la carte militaire à l'horizon
pouvez-vous me souvenir de la défense
nous indiquer la méthodologie qui sera
choisi pour mener à bien ce
redéploiement chers collègues parmi les
autres grands thèmes abordés dans le
livre blanc
j'en rêverai 2 d'une part l'accent mis
sur le renseignement
dont nous savons l'importance notamment
dans les conflits asymétriques et les
risques terroristes
d'autre part la sanctuarisation des
composants d'un reporter océaniques de
la dissuasion nucléaire qui pose la
question de leur poids dans le budget de
la défense
chers collègues l'objectif concilier
autonomie stratégique et mutualisation 5
en presque naturellement dans la volonté
affirmée dans le livre blanc a répété
par le chef de l'état de construire une
véritable europe de la défense le traité
de lisbonne a renforcé l'intégration
européenne de la politique de sécurité
et de défense commune ce pendant quatre
ans après la signature ce traité c'est à
valser tard hélas à se concrétiser
la commission de la paix à travers du
sénat a donc mis en place un groupe de
travail sur cette thématique est pour sa
part le rapport de notre collègue de
l'assemblée nationale marc électrique
halde sur la proposition de résolution
européenne sur la relance de l'europe de
la défense relève à la fois une
multiplicité d'organismes compétents qui
nuit à leur efficacité et un regrettable
manque d'ambition politique
l'engagement de nos forces armées au
mali aux côtés des comptes d'era
africaine s'il fut monsieur le ministre
une réussite militaire indéniable et
nous nous en réjouissons a jeté une
lumière crue elle sur ces deux aspects à
ce titre il est bon de souligner le
retour dans le commandement intégré
l'otan n'a pas permis cet heureux lance
d'ailleurs ce rapport voit dans la
baisse des capacités de défense et
notamment du fait de leurs contraintes
budgétaires un risque sérieux mais aussi
l'occasion à saisir pour construire
l'europe de la défense
par la mutualisation des efforts au
niveau européen comment monsieur min
sans mise avez-vous de relancer cette
coopération
car dans un contexte où notre allié
historique les états unis opèrent un
repositionnement stratégique et prend
ses distances avec les théâtres
d'opérations en méditerranée en afrique
pour privilégier un axe asie pacifique
il importe il est temps que l'europe
devienne
une véritable puissance militaire et de
défense et l'épisode de l'achat de
drones américains par la france
nécessaire que nous soutenons pas en
fait la question la coopération entre
industries européennes alors qu'il faut
admettre que nous avons raté la
révolution de ces appareils sans pilote
l'achat de drones américains tel que
décidé par le gouvernement constitue
donc aujourd'hui la meilleure option
j'ai envie de dire la seule en attendant
quand même de rattraper notre retard
technologique
alors mes chers collègues dans cette
optique le conseil européen de décembre
apparaît comme un sommet crucial
la france et l'europe sont à la croisée
des chemins il sera important de prendre
les bonnes décisions
ne ratons pas ce rendez vous merci la
parole à madame leila chi pour le groupe
écologiste
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission mes chers collègues
tout d'abord au nom d'europe écologie
les verts je voudrais rendre un hommage
aux militaires blessés cédric cordier et
à l'ensemble de nos militaires qui se
trouvent actuellement au mali notamment
mes chers collègues en 2008
les écologistes ont été autorisés à
contribuer au débat du livre blanc de la
défense
en 2012 nous avons été vertement ignoré
malgré notre insistance
nous regrettons que son élaboration
n'ait pas été l'occasion de l'expression
de l'ensemble des composantes de l'arc
républicain
il eût été plus légitime cependant si le
livre blanc a comme qualités premières
d'être un état des lieux du pouvoir
faire en matière de défense dans les dix
années qui viennent avec les moyens dont
on dispose et ce concept de la situation
du monde il n'en tire pas les conditions
adéquates
sa lecture nous laisse une impression
d'un certain et d'inachevé
le modèle budgétaire devrait intégrer
4,5 milliards de recettes
exceptionnelles
pour rappel entre 2009 et 2011 sur les
3,5 milliards de recettes attendues
exceptionnel seul 980 millions ont été
obtenues la contrainte budgétaire sous
le prisme du lobby militaro-industriel
assure déterminer la réflexion
stratégique et enfin le dogme du
nucléaire a été soustrait de la
réflexion l'outil de défense ainsi figés
dans une posture défensive d'ultime
recours circonscrit à l'intégrité
territoriale conduit au format redouté
par le général desportes la bombe et les
gendarmes et appauvrir les forces
conventionnelles en ce sens le groupe
écologiste du sénat et moi même sommes
au regret de constater des grands
l'absence des grandes orientations de
notre outil de défense bref l'absence
d'une stratégie claire l'état des
rapports des forces n'est pas abordée
lucidement il n'ya plus des nuits
désigner notre défense n'est plus
l'obsédante question de la sauvegarde de
l'intégrité de notre territoire de notre
indépendance politique de notre
existence c'est sur un continent pacifié
sur une planète dominé par la puissance
militaire des pays occidentaux que doit
être posé la question du rôle de notre
armée professionnelle
l'accroissement des dépenses d'armement
notamment des pays émergents ne doit pas
faire et lui
lyon cette augmentation doit être mise
en relation avec l'accroissement des
produits intérieurs bruts de ces pays
émergents
les forces de défense de ces pays suit
la courbe de leur montée en puissance
vers l'accession d'un statut
international en adéquation avec leur
démographie et leur économie les données
du sipri institut de référence démontre
qu'en termes de pourcentage du pib' les
dépenses d'armement demeure stable
identiquement une référence au rapport
europol 2012 quant aux chiffres du
terrorisme permet à redimensionnement de
ce danger les chiffres de repas leurs
portes 125 acte terroriste en france
dont 121 sont le set d'indépendantistes
cette donnée ne relatif le relativise
par l'atrocité de ses actes mais il
permet de donner une consistance à une
menace trop souvent fantasmée exagéré et
instrumentalisé j'en veux pour preuve
les 11450 victimes du terrorisme récent
c'est en 2012 dans le monde chiffre bien
inférieur aux 30 mille morts par armes à
feu
aux états unis après avoir fait la
guerre contre un concept contre d'autres
comme des contre des moulins
cessons de faire rechercher un ennemi
pour définir notre politique de défense
dont la plus dramatique
illustration fut la politique
outrancières et caricaturales sous
l'administration de george bush et dont
on sait qu une grande partie était
dédiée à des fins commerciales sur la
stratégie antiterroriste
le président obama dans son discours du
25 mai 2013 développe une juste analyse
en considérant je cite cette guerre
comme toutes les guerres doit prendre
fin
c'est ce que l'histoire nous conseille
c'est ce que notre démocratie exige nous
ne pouvons pas avoir recours à la force
partout sans racines une idéologie
radicale et en l'absence d'une stratégie
qui réduire l extrémisme à la source une
guerre perpétuelle via des drones des
commandos ou des déploiements militaires
seraient perdus d'avancé fin de citation
alors mes chers collègues pour être
combattue efficacement la prolifération
nucléaire et le terrorisme doivent être
analysées sans postulat idéologique loin
d'une diabolisation stérile qui
reconnaissent à experts reconnus nous
rappelle que contre la suprématie
absolue des occidentaux les stratégies
des constats des contestataires de
l'ordre international ne peuvent être
que le terrorisme et la prolifération
nucléaire
moins onéreux et plus aisé que la
recherche d'une inaccessible équilibre
conventionnelle la poursuite de nos
engagements vis-à-vis du renforcement de
la légalité internationale de la
responsabilisation des acteurs privés
comme les sociétés extractives de
minerai ou d'énergies fossiles et de
l'encadrement du commerce des armes
doivent participer en premier chef à la
stabilisation des relations
internationales cette stabilisation doit
intégrer l'impératif de la prévention
des conflits
au moment même où à la demande
exponentielle des matières premières
conjuguée aux crises énergétiques et
environnementales aux changements
climatiques accroissent les tensions le
stress environnemental constitue l'un
des tout premiers facteurs de tensions
et de faillite des états le repas le
rapport prospectif de l'union européenne
global trends de 2030 annonce une ère de
la pénurie où je cite encore la
concurrence pour les ressources
hydriques et énergétiques ainsi que les
crimes humanitaires porteuse de
déplacements de personnes et défendre
roman étatique potentiel devrait
constituer l'un des plus importants
facteurs d'affrontements d'ici 2030
d'ailleurs le président obama a lui-même
érigé le changement climatique en
priorité pour la sécurité nationale
c'était en 2008 quand la france en fera
t-elle de même - saisissable est plus
complexe certes à combattre qu'un
prétendu état voyou la donne
environnementale et énergétique est
aussi plus réel et plus menaçante un
stress nourricier hydrique climatique ne
se dissuade pas mes chers collègues un
stress nourricier hydrique climatique
s'inscrit dans la prévention que nous
peinons à théoriser un stress nourricier
hydrique et climatiques prend tout son
sens dans la mise en oeuvre de la
stratégie de la protection que nous
prétendons porter une course aux
matières premières ne nous arbitrera pas
plus à la canonnière qu'avec des appels
à la vertu et quid des 250 millions de
réfugiés climatiques que prévoit l'onu
en 2050 mais sert collègues les conflits
du 21ème siècle ne sont plus les
flea du siècle précédent l'opération
sert valait pourtant une leçon
magistrale du prix humain et financier
de la restauration de l'autorité d'un
état corrompu érodé par son incapacité à
gérer les aléas climatiques les
conditions de la paix réside dans le
désamorçage précoce des crises
environnementales et énergétiques qui se
profile la prévention des conflits doit
être une priorité
un secrétariat d'état des qui est
permettraient de structure et de
coordonner l'action de l'état en ce sens
les capacités des armées doivent être
repensés en conséquence les anglo saxons
l'ont déjà conceptualiser à nous de
développer notre doctrine écosystémiques
notre green différence la transition
environnementale des armées est née
logiquement de l'appréciation
géopolitique de nos dépendances en
matières premières et de notre volonté
d'enrayer un monde de compétition
belligène au delà du constat des enjeux
et des risques
c'est la question de nos moyens pour y
répondre qui est éludée par le livre
blanc nous devons dressant un bilan de
nos possibilités
la france n'a plus les moyens de la
grandiloquence les dom com ne donne pas
la capacité à la france de peser dans
l'océan pacifique ou indiens pourtant la
france non seulement et la seconde
puissance maritime avec 11 millions 200
mille deux cent mille kilomètres carrés
d'eaux territoriales
mais elle est aussi la première
puissance maritime mondiale par sa
biodiversité dont je vous rappelle qu'il
est le troisième au monde en termes de
volume
après le trafic d'armes et de drogue la
doctrine de la défense tout azimut tient
plus du discours que de la réalité
notre défense ne peut se concevoir en
dehors de nos schémas d'alliance la
géographie ne multiplie pas les
capacités mais les coûts et les
contraintes la géographie française
dicte les prémices de notre politique de
défense
une politique d'alliance et de promotion
de la sécurité collective onusienne
l'intervention au mali n'aurait pas été
possible sans l'appui logistique et les
moyens d'observation anglo-américain les
américains en évoquant la facturation
possible de ce soutien nous ont délivré
un message clair il ne soit plus être
les supplétifs de nos ambitions qui
pourrait le leur reprocher nous devons
fixer notre cadre d'action géographique
et développer résolument l'échelon
europe
1 les axes prioritaires définis par le
livre blanc rejoignent la géographie de
l' influence française
c'est une avant une avancée notable
vis-à-vis du pressante du précédent
livre blanc cependant malgré l'annoncé
d'une relance de l'europe de la défense
et d'un livre blanc européen
force est de constater que cette europe
de la défense sur ajoutera à une
dissuasion nationale l'europe de la
défense ne doit pas être pensé comme une
défense d'appoint l'europe doit
construire une identité de sécurité et
de défense de premier plan à
l'alternative entre politiques des
moyens ou politique d'ambition
le choix des écologistes est celui d'une
politique du réel et du pragmatisme face
à l'origine environnementales et
énergétiques des conflits à venir
nous quittons l'hémicycle du sénat mais
nous reviendrons dans notre édition de
19h plus largement sur cette question du
livre blanc de la défense mais tout de
suite c'est l'émission politique de la
rédaction de public sénat
preuve par 3 qui reçoit ce soir jean
vincent placé c'est le président du
groupe écologiste du sénat bonne soirée
à tous